the Iran deal was regarded as Barack
Obama's signature International
achievement Iran met its preliminary
pledges the U.S the EU and the United
Nations responded by repealing or
suspending sanctions but the deal didn't
survive a change of administration in
the U.S the fact is this was a horrible
one-sided deal that should have never
ever been made
it didn't bring calm it didn't bring
peace
and it never will
among the consequences was an upsurge in
social unrest in Iran as crippling
sanctions were reintroduced but
throughout all of this Iran resumed a
robust nuclear program starting to
enrich 60 uranium and moving closer to
achieving weaponized nuclear capacity we
are now in a situation in which during
the jcpoa Iran would need at least a
year to be able to amass the material
for a single nuclear weapon right now it
has enough material for five and it only
needs about 10 days to enrich that
material to weapons-grade levels
during his presidential campaign Joe
Biden pledged to reinstate the Iran deal
along with several other International
treaties at the Trump administration had
walked away from
immediately after assuming office
President Biden used executive orders to
return the U.S to the Paris agreement
and the World Health Organization he
could have rejoined the Iran deal in
exactly the same way but chose not to he
sent his secretary of state to repair
relations with allies ruptured during
the Trump era but restoring U.S
participation in the joint comprehensive
plan of action did not appear to be on
the agenda although the aim of
preventing Iran from developing its
nuclear capacity was
the single Trump Administration deal
backed by Biden are the Abraham Accords
a series of treaties normalizing
diplomatic relations between Israel and
its Arab neighbors including the United
Arab Emirates and Bahrain
it is intent on bringing Saudi Arabia to
the table as well relying on one
critical Factor like all the signatories
to the Abraham Accord Saudi Arabia has a
strong antipathy towards Iran while
there have been recent signs of
reproachment between the two countries
this dislike is very much the glue that
holds us nato in the Gulf together as is
the opposition to the jcpoa
it's a fact that the Biden
Administration is well aware of as it
seeks to finish building a U.S
supporting Alliance in the Gulf any U.S
return to the Iran deal would imperil
this process so effectively a choice has
been made
Hannah Al Jazeera Washington